Two.
One.
Hello Michelle. How's it going? And
really crack my neck. Oh, go ahead.
Crack your neck. Put it up. Put the
microphone to it so we can hear it.
Does it pop? Ooh, that was a good one.
That was a good one.
Did you do that all the time?
It's just when I'm getting ready
to throw down. Pull this up.
Microphone. Like a fist from your face.
There we go. Yeah. Perfect. Perfect.
So what's happening?
No, we're just in town. Um, uh,
my brother in law just moved,
just got stationed here in California,
so we drove them down and then we
did the whole, um, no, I think it's,
it's actually an hour south of here.
I think it's not close by,
but cool air force.
And so we did the whole thing.
Yes. Yeah. So he got stationed there.
That was the first time I ever
saw, um, a stealth bomber.
It was like at right after nine
one, one we were filming, um, uh,
fear factor out there and I saw one fly
overhead. It's like a Ufo was like, wow,
that is crazy. Does it look like a
Ufo? Yeah. It doesn't even look real.
You ever seen one in real life? It
looks like, Huh? Like a Batmobile, like,
like Batman's plane. It's so crazy when
you see one fly and you're like, wow,
the engineering involved in
something like that. It's insane.
And that was a while back. Yeah, sure.
It was 2001 because it
was right after nine 11.
So it was 2000 that's it right there.
That's what we saw on of them.
One of them is a,
there's,
it'd be two and this is like a
f one 16 or something like that.
I don't know which one we saw,
but it was black and wicked looking
nice.
That's crazy.
It looks like your Tesla flying
around and one of those things.
That's what we thought. Imagine back then,
that's what it looked like back then.
So what, what, what is there
now? You probably can't see him.
I'd probably look like the sky. I
probably owe you from military background.
My Dad. Yeah, my dad was him.
So that's where my parents met.
My Dad was stationed in Germany.
My mom was fleeing Thailand.
Um,
to her, her first husband was
like physically abusive to her.
So she was leaving Thailand and she came
to Germany to find her a Gi and then
found my dad. She came to find a
Gi specifically. Well, you know,
I think she's coming to get away,
but she wanted to,
she wanted a better life
for her son at the time.
And my dad was in the hospital and so my
mom was taking care of them and cooking
and food and made him fall in love it.
My Dad always jokes, he says, he tells
us a story all the time. He's like, yeah,
your mom was taking care of me.
And then she told me that you were
pregnant and then 12 months later you were
born. Oh, that's funny. So,
but now they fell in love.
It was just a really long pregnancy.
This weird, just kind of weird.
I don't know why.
Yes,
I don't know. But that was
very small, but no. Yeah.
And then so then we moved to Colorado
and I was born then we lived in Germany
for a little bit when I was younger.
And then back to Colorado and I grew
up in Aurora, Colorado. Oh, cool.
When did you start training? Um, probably
around 10. Yeah. Yeah, around 10.
Um, I have, I have an older brother,
he's four years older than me.
He's my half brother. And, um,
I really wanted to do gymnastics
as a kid and my parents just,
we just couldn't afford, it was really
expensive. And so my brother found, um,
a little karate spot at the church,
just across the street and it was
a community, like a community,
a karate thing. And so it's something that
all three of us could do. And so yeah,
we jumped into it and I fell
in love with it. I just,
it just took over my life and changed,
changed my life.
Did you start competing really
quickly? Yeah, I think so. Um,
and at first it's funny because at first,
um,
so I would do like the karate tournament
and so there's point sparring and then
there's the Cahtos and I
thought the Cahtos were silly.
And I remember going in and doing point
sparring and I'm getting knocked on my
button. I was like, okay, I think I,
I want to do some cod is then I want
to bring some trophies home. So,
but um, so yeah, I competed co put uh,
karate from 10 all the
way up until I was 18.
And so I did a lot of the like the
flashy, like, um, extreme martial arts,
Carter's with the, um, like the flips
and stuff like that. But I always,
I always came back to sparring
because I wasn't good at it.
Like I was like, ah, it, it
bugged me. It bugged me that
I, that I wasn't good at it.
And then I found my niche
because it's point sparring,
so you get to two points to
the head for kicks to the head.
So I would just sit back and let him
come in and just kick him in the head.
I'm Cuban had come
times and win the fight.
So how did you go from that to,
did you go from that to kickboxing
or did you go right into MMA?
Like when did you,
when did you just start training?
So,
so I did,
I did karate and then I got
my black belt in karate,
what kind of American freestyle.
And then,
so I think around 18 or 19,
I was kind of just exploring,
doing a couple of different things.
So I did,
we'll shoot for a couple of years and I
competed in wool shoe and then I did a
little bit of Campbell and um,
and then kind of dabbled a
little bit into um, kickboxing.
And uh,
so it,
it kind of just happened pretty strangely.
I was in college,
I was working at Hooters and I was doing
the, all these like little side jobs.
I'm like, fuck doing photo
shoots for this and that. And um,
I was a ring girl for MMA shell.
I hadn't ever seen MMA.
And I remember,
uh,
just walking around the cage and
thinking I want to be like on the inside.
I that one that looks cool.
I think I could do it cause it
was mixed martial arts, you know,
and I remember talking to her motor and
he kind of laughed me off and was just
like, whatever, you know,
you're a ring girl. And, um,
it was a smaller local show.
Donald Cerrone was actually fighting on
that show and he overheard me yeah. In,
so he came to my work at Hooters and I
wasn't there and he was just like left me
know if serious about fighting, get your
ass in the gym. Wow. Then there was,
this is in Colorado,
Colorado. And then I saw,
I went to go train and went to go train
and wood with Donald and you know, we, we,
Jim hopped from place to play is
I trained with, um, with Duane.
I trained, um, with Trevor.
I trained with, with, with
all the guys. Wow. And, um,
and so I took a couple of
smokers would drive, you know,
drive around the region and, and
took a couple smokers and then, um,
it was like at that point when
I was still in college and, um,
I just was not happy in college.
I,
I was kind of wandering around aimlessly
is really successful in high school and
uh, you know, um,
it just didn't transfer over to college.
I, I still, I got good grades. I was 3.8,
you know, I was going to do
you, but I wasn't happy. I just,
I there was something missing and it was,
it was the martial arts.
So this is a big part of my life.
And you needed a real challenge. Yeah.
It's something physical to probably right.
Yeah.
I would imagine that someone growing up
doing martial arts as long as you did,
you like the thrill of using
your body and moving around.
It's like that it's so important.
Like once,
once you do that and you compete
and it's becomes a part of,
you did the idea of like sitting in the
classroom all day and then eventually
sitting in a job all day, that's
probably not, not that compelling.
Yeah, I think so. I think that, um,
I just loved going to school for,
I was going to school,
so I was double majoring in
theater and sports science.
So was majoring in theater because I
got a scholarship for it and I was doing
sports science. I wanted to be
like physical therapist for um,
like a sports team or something like
that or even a martial arts team. But uh,
yeah, so I, I decided to take a,
like a little bit like a
break from that and my mom,
my grandma was sick in Thailand.
So then I was like, I told my mom,
I just go with her for the summer and
he went to visit my grandma and Thailand
and all those out there. I, um,
I went to sit your tongue more Thai camp
and I absolutely fell in love with it.
They made fun of me because of my,
my karate kicks.
Yeah. It's interesting how, how different
karate kicks are. Yeah. Thai kicks.
Yeah. And they were looking at me like
I was crazy, but it was like, but no,
I'm a black belt.
I know what I'm doing there.
Just laughing at me with
training on concrete outside
these little five year old
kids are doing 10 year old,
10 minute rounds. And um,
my feet are blistering up from kicking
and over and over on the concrete.
But I loved it.
I fell in love with it.
It kicked my butt and I fell in love
with it and I came back and I dropped out
of college and I decided to
pursue fighting. Wow. So
where did you learn grappling?
It's so,
so my first MMA fight was kind of just,
it was supposed to be an amateur
fight and I'm, like I said,
it was training with,
um,
with Donald and he was
training at a school in Vail.
And so I would, I would
go to, I would, um,
I would work on the weekends and
then drive up to Vail and train,
uh, my grappling and all of it, like
the, like all of the MMA. And so,
so you basically train MMA together. He
didn't take specific grapping in classes,
but would've imagined that that was the
thing that you needed to concentrate on
the most,
right?
[inaudible]. Yeah. And I figured, okay,
is my, my, my pro day or it wasn't,
it was supposed to be amateur,
but the girl that I was supposed to
fight fell through and I'm the only girl
that they had available was already
pro. She was like two, no pro.
And of course you know how Donald is,
he's like, whatever. Fuck it, just do it.
And so that's a good Donald
accent. So I was like, all right.
I mean we've been training.
So I literally had four weeks in my,
um, in my, like throughout
my, my karate career,
we would have grappling nights
when we would do grappling,
but it wasn't anything like
substantial. So yeah, four weeks of,
of grappling training and
I figured, okay, you know,
I'll just use my stand up to,
to win the fight.
And she was swinging from, from way back
here and trying to take my head off.
So I ended up taking her down.
I ended up taking down like
six or seven times and,
and winning the fight by taking
her down in ground and pounding.
That's crazy. Yeah. That's crazy. Did you
say while you were doing it? Like, wow,
this is so weird that I'm doing this.
It was,
I wasn't thinking at all. I was just in
the moment having the time of my life.
Were you thinking that this was
what you're going to wind up doing,
like professionally or were you just
thinking, I can't believe I'm doing this?
I, yeah, that's exactly what I
was like, this is so much fun. Um,
it was that the Broomfield events or not,
I dunno if that's still called
the Broomfield, the Ben Center
in Colorado, but yeah, I think a
bank owns it now or something. Yeah,
those changed names. It was so much fun,
but never in my life. I thought I would,
I would be a top UFC contender.
Never. And on your way,
your goal is to be the first mommy yeah.
To ever a title. Yeah. That's possible.
100%. You're in the, you're in the hunt
right now. Like what are you ranked? Um,
ranked seven,
seventh,
but I don't think the
rankings are anything.
They're weird. They're weird. Yeah.
There's like sometimes someone will beat
somebody and then that person is still
ahead of in the racking. I'm
like, explain that. I just,
I don't understand the rankings though.
I feel like I've,
I've won my last two fights and I've
gone down and rankings you want to,
hasn't fought and she's
gone down in rankings. Um,
and some of the girls haven't fought
and they've gone up and rankings. Uh,
I just think the rankings are crazy.
Yeah.
Well it's a bunch of people get
to submit their positions. Right.
Like a bunch of journalists
and excepted experts on MMA.
Good to have an idea.
I guess when I look at them and,
because sometimes I feel like it shifts
depending on who they're trying to push
or, you know, just sometimes I feel
like just storyline kind of can dictate.
Yeah. The, the rankings, you know,
obviously I'm a giant fan of the UFC.
I loved them to death.
I'm so happy and I just would do
nothing for any other organization.
They never want to work
for another organization,
but I don't like the way they do things.
There's a lot of things that I don't like.
They just stay as cut.
Elias Theodora really? Yeah.
One loss. Derek Robertson cut.
I'm like what? They cut Derek Beth. No,
he lost the dark hair. I was like, what?
Just one. I'm like, explain that.
How do you explain that one?
That one doesn't make any sense.
There's like some match ups don't
make any sense. Interim title shots.
Those are preposterous. It's crazy. Yeah.
I mean I understand it's, it's as machine,
it has to work and they're
trying, but it just, it, um,
especially for like a fighter
whose life depends on yeah,
the fights and you know,
your livelihood depends on that and
for it do you just to be out. Yeah.
It's stressful enough to only fight a
couple of times a year because you have to
divvy up that, that person
money throughout those
times, you know? But yeah.
Well I think
pupil like you are very important for
women's MMA because you seem so normal.
You know what I mean? Like there's some
women, you talked to them, you're like,
well, this girl's fucking crazy.
No wonder why she's a fighter.
You know what I mean?
Like there's some girls that are real
aggressive or just that like you talked to
Amanda Nunez. You like, I
get it. Yeah. She should be
a fighter. She's, she's cool.
She's so cool. She's so cool.
But that's a bad ass bitch. Yeah.
You know what I mean? She'll
fuck people up. You could tell.
You could tell just looking at her,
you know, like the way she's built.
She's wide did. You can tell she's
got power and she looks like a girl.
You would not want to fuck with
Josh. You called it, Josh called it. He
said, ETF that she'd knock out Cyborg.
That was crazy. That was
crazy that that was, I didn't,
I didn't think that she could
knock her out. I thought,
I think she could knock out anyone.
I mean, I think she could not.
I think Amanda Nunez can knock out a
lot of guys. She hits so hard. Yeah.
But I thought that there would
be a big weight disadvantage.
Cyborg has a tremendous
experience advantage,
and she's never shown herself to
be someone that gets hurt. Yeah.
But even when she fought Juliana bars,
did you ever see that fight in lion fight?
I
remember seeing highlights of it
cause she's just like stuck in the uh,
on the ropes and Georgina is a elite
and Cyborg got dropped and kept coming
and mean she was pursuing her in the
final rounds.
Yeah.
I mean she was chasing after she lost
the decision but she gained a lot of fans
because she didn't have any pro Moy Thai
fights and she fought a woman who like
she couldn't get a fight for almost
three years cause girls were ducking her.
Yeah cause they didn't want to fight
her more ties. Brutal. I feel like
because my husband and I
talk about this all the time,
cause it MMA you have options.
Like if you have,
if you're having trouble in the stand up,
you can take them down,
you can work your grappling this or that.
In boxing you don't really have
much options. Either you give up,
you get knocked out or you give
up, you know, in the corner.
And I felt the same way in might type
set for now you're introducing knees and
Shins and elbows. Yeah. Cut.
And you have no way out.
Like, yeah. You know, so that's,
yeah, that's a rough sport and an
incredibly exciting sports watch.
And one that I've never understood me
boxing so gigantic in this country and
Moitai has almost no
presence. And I, I've just,
it baffles me to no end. I mean that
they have the product. Yeah. I mean,
and they have great American fighters.
I mean like Joe Schilling, Kevin Ross,
and there's, there's a ton of them
and this guys like John Wayne,
par from Australia and all these
guys are exciting to watch and fun.
And then there's so many
elite kids that are coming up,
but there's no mainstream appeal. It
doesn't, I don't understand that. No, no.
I either,
yeah,
that is crazy to think they need a thing
like the UFC or something comes along
and they dump a ton of money into it.
But the thing is like, there's only,
people only have so much time to
watch things, so it's like, oh,
Deontay wilder is fighting. I'll
watch that. Oh, you know, uh,
Tyron Woodley's fighting. I'll watch
him. Yeah. Oh, Jon Jones is fighting.
I'll watch that. What's
this? Moitai ah, this fights.
I'm going to watch Bella towards debt.
I'm going to watch that instead.
It's like there's, it's almost like too
saturated. Yeah, that's true. But it's,
it's a shame. It'd be cool if they had
like a card with all different types of,
of fighting. That's what one does. You
know, the all on the same night. Yes.
One FC does that.
They'll have kickboxing,
Muay Thai MMA in one night
and they'll have no, no,
they let everybody know
this is what they're doing.
I think one is doing fantastic.
They're there. They're doing their,
they're putting on amazing fights.
I mean,
and we've seen that these are like
legitimately worldclass fighters.
They're beating guys like they,
you know, um, Timothy nuts.
You can just beat Eddie Alvarez knocked
him out and that was crazy. Yeah.
And they're also,
they cut out all the weight cutting.
There's no way cutting over there.
So like when sage Northcutt fought a
cosmo Alexandra [inaudible] vitamin 185
pounds because that's really what
he walks around. Yeah. You know,
so there's no way cutting
over there was a brutal hit.
Then he got caught with crazy. I'm,
I'm glad that he's okay, but he's okay.
But yeah, his, his faces
had eight fractures.
Do you think it's better for him to
cut down? That's a good question.
Very good question. Because I
mean, if he's getting knocked out
by that,
and I'm wondering if maybe he should
be walking around lighter or if,
I don't know,
cause he's pretty lean already
his lien, but that's, that
fight played out realistically.
Uh, not, not that it's better for him or
worse for him, but sage is a young guy.
He's 21 or 22 years old.
He's got a limited amount of
worldclass Moitai experience.
He fought cosmo who was a multiple
time world champion. Yeah.
And it's just a bad
fight. Why, why did they,
why would they set that up
if they're trying to build
them? It's easy to like, I,
I've said that too. And people were like,
oh, it's easy to say after the fact,
you're right. But if I was in
sage as corner going, hey bro,
there's a lot of fights we should take.
And that was [inaudible] knows
who's an MMA fight. Okay.
But sage is not a wrestler. Yeah. I
mean he has taken guys down before,
but I would absolutely
say that's the game plan.
The game plan is tie this guy up
and drag him to the ground. Don't,
don't be standing with us.
I just feel like if you've,
if you have a background in something,
in stressful situations, you always
revert back to what you know. Sure.
Yeah. So even if he did work as wrestling,
he's gonna Revert back to his, you know,
really hoppy movie stance and, and
that's, that's what it looked like.
What happened? He was kind of pulling
out, hop and back and got caught. Yeah.
Well he was trying that sideways
karate style stance. You know,
Cosmo's just super elite.
And you saw if you saw the fight,
he fainted a couple times with the left.
He set them up like with
a switch a couple times.
And then as sage circled off,
he went to his right and cracked him.
Well, that guy's just a
super elite fighter. I mean,
when it comes to striking,
I feel like that is where being elite
is the most dangerous for an opponent.
You know? Uh, I feel like if someone,
if you find an elite Jujitsu guy and
he catches you and he submits you,
you live another day, you know, like
Neil magazine, Damien Maia, we found out,
you know, Damian gets him to the ground
and just strangles him, right? Yeah.
But that's,
he'll be all right if you get
chaos by an elite striker.
Who knows what kind of damage
happens to you. You know, when,
when his face got broken and he's
had eight fractures in his face,
his cheek, his warbird old, they had
a piece them back together again.
He chose attached. Do
you know? I don't know.
I don't know the extent of the injuries.
He, she, he posted up some images though.
Did you see the images of the x
rays? It's like, whoa. Like this is,
it was horrible.
Yeah.
I mean so,
so that's how I feel against,
um,
do you do to people when
they submit me I'm like, ah,
okay. Like let's do it again.
Yeah, exactly. Well, what about
unjudged and rose? I was scared.
I was scared for rose.
Was it really bad landing landing on
her neck, like that was terrifying.
Lots of it scared me just
cause we were in Brazil to,
that crowd was crazy and everybody shot
up and started screaming and rose just
like
laid out on the canvas and I kind of was
just like wanting her corner to be in
there with her cause she was just
all alone by herself, you know?
And I was worried that she wasn't
going to get up. I was like, Hey,
you guys like wait to cheer until we
see she's okay. Cause that can parallel.
If you look at the impact, have you seen
the photograph of the landing itself?
I mean it's, it's one of the
worst ways you get ever land.
She's essentially headfirst with the neck,
sideways and um,
flat or negative space. Yeah. It's
like someone was cranking on her neck.
I was like, horrible. Yeah, that was a bad
landing. I mean the whole thing was bad.
She's going for the Camorra.
Um, Jessica picks her up.
She doesn't lace a leg and she
holds onto the Camorra, which you,
you just can't do. You just can't do it.
You got to let it go know. But she, she's,
she's held on to things
before and you know,
and caught armbars and triangles and
it's one of those things, you know,
you make a mistake.
So,
cause I know people were talking about
it being illegal to slam somebody like
that. She didn't do it on purpose.
She just tried to slam her.
I mean she's just trying to take,
lift her up and dump it down.
I mean the illegal slamming is
like when Minataro fought Bob Sapp.
Do you remember that?
Nope.
Military fought Bob Sapp and Bob Sapp
literally got them in a pile driver where
he scooped and Bob Sapp was 370 pounds
with abs and on everything that Mexico
has to offer, every steroid that
was available. Bob Sapp was on.
They said that he used to
travel with like a briefcase.
Phil would roids I mean he was a
goddamn science project at one point.
It was fascinating to watch,
right? Because I think to this day,
that was probably one of the greatest
victories in all of MMA. Minataro who was,
he was outweighed by a good
solid hundred and 3,040 pounds,
like legitimately and still
got an arm bar off Bob Sapp.
Jamie got it. Yeah. Watch this.
So look at the size difference.
First of all, just see the beginning of
the fight scene. So he shoots, he shoots,
but look at the size difference when
you see them come out. It is so crazy.
Bob Sapp was so big,
but look at this. Boom.
So that now many Taros neck was
fucked up from that forever.
Like that haunted him his
entire career. Watch this. Boom.
Yup.
See He tucks his head a little bit at
the last second so he doesn't catch it on
the top of the head, but all
of his weight, all of Bob
Sam's. Wait, look at that.
Why don't you think he tucked it? I
think it just gave him, he kept going.
Any fucking submitted them?
We have a,
Toro was one of the toughest guys that's
ever walked the face of the planet.
Look at this. He scoots out. He
escapes and gets on top of them.
Yeah.
Well look at the size difference.
500 and [inaudible] I mean he,
Bob was so big and he's probably
on Epo fucking everything.
And Look, look at that.
Just wind millin with his legs. He
was, and he was trained by Maury Smith.
You know, Maurice was training. I'm
so, he was a legitimate, uh, you know,
it will legitimately trained athlete
and he was so big. So these were,
this is back in the day when
there's like 10 minute rounds,
10 minute first round. So
Minotaur, I believe I went
into the second round though.
I want to say,
oh my God.
Don't remember entirely whether it went
into the second round, but I want to say,
yeah, yeah. I mean, look,
he beat her Nesto who's
twice in kickboxing matches,
but also goes to show you how hard cro
cop punches cause cro cop flattened him
with one punch.
[inaudible] broke his orbital
bone with a straight left.
So Minataro eventually
gets him on his back.
And then once he gets him
on his bag as Bob Sapp,
like you can only keep 375
pounds going for so long. I mean,
he's just completely exhausted.
Steroids. You do. Yeah.
So this is the end.
He ties up his arm and catches him
in an arm bar and Bob's have taps.
And I was at my friend
fuck whose house was at,
but I was with Eddie Bravo when
we saw this and were screaming,
we couldn't believe it. We
couldn't believe it because
it was like a victory for,
it was a victory for technique, you
know? That's what it was. It was,
it was a victory for Jujitsu was a
victory for technique over broad.
And there's a perfect example
of technique over brawn.
Not that material doesn't have Bron
and not that Bob Sapp doesn't have
techniques, but if they're the same
size, Minataro would've fucked him up.
It would've been,
it would've been an easy fight for him.
It's just weather the storm and wasn't
scared to be in there with them. Yeah.
Fader wouldn't fight them.
Faders said fucked up.
They offered fatal or fight with
pop size like, Nah, I'm good.
And he fought Hahnemann Choi when hundred
and Troy was like seven feet tall.
You remember that fight caught him in
there was was one of the most ridiculous
armbars ever.
He caught him in an arm bar and the
arm is as long as this fucking table.
It's so crazy.
That was a ridiculous armbar ridiculous.
Armbar but you'll never see any
fights like that happen. Not Anymore.
Well, I still think someone, someone
might do it. Yeah. Rise and could do it.
There's two do fucked up
things with Gabby Garcia.
You've seen that hazy Gabby Garcia's
a science project and a half.
That's crazy. What is
that? What's going on? Uh,
not that I'm aware of. How are they going
to find someone? A woman is 240 pounds.
She's 240 pounds jacked and she's legit
black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu and
she's, you know, she's legitimately
tough. I thought I saw the video of her.
I'm grappling with Mckinsey and Mckinsey,
like almost the Kinsey bitter,
I think Mckinsey Vader in a Jujitsu match.
And did you do too much?
But in MMA I'll take anybody's be here.
Yeah.
I think Mackenzie either beat her
or how to draw one an advantage,
something like that. But it is, it is.
That's science. Okay. You're,
you're, you're doing some stuff.
You're doing some stuff
to people that it's not,
your body's not supposed to have that
in their lady. It's not, you know,
I mean it's, it's interesting cause
like, like the Bob Sapp thing,
like you get to see what happens.
Wow. Okay. This is what's,
when someone just goes for it.
And when pride,
ensign anyway was on the podcast and he,
and since hilarious,
he was detailing the contract, he goes,
like, it's said in all capital letters,
we will not test you for steroids.
They were like,
that's what joy would tell me
all the time. Joey visa. No,
he's been in my shore for the
last couple of fights. Joe,
he's an excellent fighter, man. He would
say that. He said it almost, they almost,
um, encouraged courage. Not almost,
they basically did encourage it because
they just wanted to see crazy things
that like came out of comic books. You
know, they wanted you to be jacked.
They wanted you to be gigantic. Yeah.
I mean as long as everybody's doing it,
I guess I would never,
I wouldn't want to do that.
Even if I had the choice to do it. You
wouldn't want to write one too. Right.
I get it.
Will that makes sense.
And that's why I think people like you
were important for MMA because you are,
you're a woman. You seem like a
woman. You behave like a woman.
You look at a woman,
if someone say [inaudible] top 10 UFC
fight or you'd be like, what? No Way.
Really. She's so normal.
But if you saw it,
Gabby Garcia and you know that
girl's smashing people in Japan,
like I fucking believe it
out of this room cause she hops
out and starts a flattened me.
I just like, I feel like it takes the, um,
the jaw.
I feel like it would take the joy out of
a victory for if you did steroids. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, you would
become something different.
The reality is a woman becomes something
different when she starts taking male
hormones. You just do. He
becomes something different.
Your tendons strengthen.
Your bone structure changes.
Your voice deepens.
You become much more like a man. I mean,
that's when you see transgender women,
when a woman rather is a transgender man,
she decides she wants to be a man.
They start taking testosterone,
they get beards, they have all sorts
of strange things happen down below,
and they, they start having a deeper voice
and they sound like a man then that's,
that's exactly what happens to a woman
when a woman takes steroids if she's not
trying to transition.
So same thing.
You just taking male hormones that
make your muscles grow far larger than
they're supposed to.
Yeah.
I remember watching a movie
that they did in Thailand.
It's called beautiful boxer. Yes,
yes. Yeah. It's the opposite. He, yes,
he wanted to be a woman, but I think
he did it the right way. Right.
If there's a right way to do it because,
well,
he started as a man and then became
a woman and kept fighting men.
Yes. And I think that someone should
have told her at the time, like,
let's just stop fighting. Let's stop
fighting. Or I, this is my take on it.
Like that she needed to keep fighting
so that she could pay for the surgery.
Yeah.
Yeah. All right. Catch 22 if
I ever was one. Yeah. Yeah,
but would it was an elite fighter until
the transition and then you see the
skills start to diminish because
there's no more testosterone when she's
fighting men.
But if she was fighting women,
she would have a giant
advantage still over women.
And I don't think that's right either.
I don't think that's fair either.
No one does. No one does accept
transgender people, transgender people,
and super progressive activists
who have no idea how sports work.
It's,
those are the people,
the people that just want inclusiveness
and they just want everyone to be okay.
And you know, maybe this is the
world I'm looking for. I'm looking,
I'm looking towards a world where
everyone's included. Yeah. Good.
Have a transgender league. I
have a transgender division.
No, I'm cool with that.
I'll be happily happily support them.
But you're pretending that
that's a woman and it's not.
It's a male who's transitioning to a
woman. You have an x, y chromosome.
It's a different thing. Yeah. You
know, I'm 100% if a woman says,
I want to fight a transgender woman.
Okay, I'm a hundred that's fine. Yeah.
But like for leagues to recognize that
this is the same thing and like to say
like how would you feel if all of the
UFC is weight classes in the women's
division,
we're dominated by transgender women.
I would feel like there were some,
I feel like I should not say
something. Right, right, right. Yeah.
Like I'm going to get caught up.
Yeah. Let me talk for you to fucking
bullshit. It's fucking bullshit, right?
Yeah.
You don't have to say anything.
And that's how girls feel right now
when there's sports being dominated and
track and field. Yeah.
That's okay. That's not fair.
[inaudible]. I mean, I as, I guess for me,
I've always been, especially like being
a female in a male dominant sport,
I've always, I've, I guess if I can let
the like to consider myself a feminist,
not, not so much a feminist, but
I like when I go into the gym, I,
my teammates look at me as a fighter.
Like they don't look at me as a
female fight or anything like that.
They look at me as their teammate,
you know what I mean? And the,
and I appreciate that. I appreciate that
they trade, treat me as an athlete and,
and,
and all of that good stuff.
But I feel like w like
at the end of the day,
like girls need to fight girls and
guys need to fight guys. We like,
we have different strengths than the
guys do and the guys have different
strengths in the girls do and,
and it's nice for us to have a place
so that we can showcase our skills.
Yes,
I agree.
I think the only problem that I have
with that transitioning thing is physical
competition.
That's it.
Physical competition against the gender
that you supposedly aligned with. Yeah.
Yeah. You can't do it, but here's what
you don't see. Here's what you don't see.
You don't see a lot of transgender
men who want to fight men.
You don't see a lot of women
who are taking hormones, uh,
to become a man who want to
fight men. Yeah. Good. Fucking
luck with that, ladies.
Yeah, good luck. Stop. This is crazy.
Like this idea that you just magically
become a woman or you just magically
become a man.
It's just not true.
And athletes recognize it and
rational people recognize it,
but there's so much pushback from
progressive people who it's like what
percentage of the population and we
even talking about here and we as a,
it's not even 1% it's a very
strange thing that it's,
it's taking over the conversation
with bathrooms and competition,
sports and so many different things.
I'm all for inclusiveness and I'm all
for being open minded and letting,
letting people do you whatever you want
to be yourself. Be Whatever yourself is.
I don't know what yourself,
I don't know what you feel,
but you can't compete against
women. That's, it's that simple.
It's really that simple. It has, it
has to be something deeper where they,
you know, it and to me, I think
it goes back to like that mental,
like a mental block where you,
where you need some like a false
sense of confidence. Yes. I feel like,
what's like sand bagging? It really is.
It really, it is the ultimate sandbag.
It's like, Oh, I'm a
woman. Like, wait a minute.
Where the fuck did you get those hands?
That's really like the ultimate
form of sex. I mean everybody,
for folks who don't know
what sandbagging is, oh,
I was going to bring up smokers too.
For folks who don't know what smokers is.
If you listen to this podcast,
the smoker is small amateur fights that
they have in gyms or little arenas,
a high school gym, stuff like that.
But, um, uh, sandbagging is like,
say if Michelle had a black belt in
Jujitsu and then entered into a judo
tournament as a white belt and then
just fucking flying armbar everybody,
they'd be like, what the hell is this?
Where'd you get your white belts?
Like how do you have a white belt? But
we've all seen things like that before.
Everyone has seen things like that before.
There's people that pretend they're
a younger than they really are.
They pretend they're lighter
than they really are.
They pretend they cause they want to win.
This is no different. It's no different.
It really is.
And the people who don't understand it,
they have never competed in high level
athletics. It's really that simple.
If you've competed in
high level athletics,
you know that there's a differentiation.
There's a difference
between men and women.
And there's a reason why we have a
man's division in a women's division.
It's not that anybody's better or worse,
it's just like there's unfair advantages
like the Bob Sapp mandatorial thing.
That was an unfair advantage.
It's just overcome by someone who
have superior skill and an iron will.
And that's what Minataro
was when he beat Bob Sapp.
I mean there's no denying that one
guy was way bigger and way stronger,
but it was overcome. You shouldn't
force people to overcome. It should be,
even if they were, even if Minataro and
Bob Sapp or even here's the fight, shoot,
take down, Dang on his back.
Armbar Bang fights over.
It'd be like a couple minutes
maximum admin Atar would armbar yeah.
What do you think it's because people
like to see the mismatch and maybe like
that underdog story where the person
that is, you know, the underdog wins.
Yeah, like mandatory, but like again,
minutes Harlow's neck is still
fucked up to this deck. You know,
his neck bothered him.
His entire, from that one
pile driver, three hours, 75 pounds,
plus his weight all on his neck. It just
shows you how fucking tough dot guy is.
You know, the [inaudible] story was
run over by a truck when he was a kid.
That's way as this giant scar on his back.
Like he was in the hospital for like a
year. He's at the Carson animal. I mean,
he's as tough as they go.
I got hit by a truck. You're not going
to do nothing to me. You can't force it,
everyone to be that tough.
You know?
I think it's important to have fairness
in this. This is why I'm so pro Usada.
I love what they're doing.
I love the fact that they're
testing the shit out of people.
They're just showing up at people's
houses at six o'clock in the morning, hey,
wake up time for a test.
And but is it the same
in, in every country? Um,
that's a good question. It's
a very good question. Right?
Someone's training in Russia
or Germany or wherever. Yeah,
that's a very good question.
I do not know the answer to that
because I know that's kind of one of the
concerns for some of
the athletes that yeah,
it might be really strict
here in the states,
but in other states or is it as strict?
Right.
Because it is u s antidoping
agency that's Usada. Yeah,
that's a good question. Yeah. So what
do you think if you don't think it is,
I don't know. I'll talk for you. Is there
something fucked up you need to say,
just go like this. I don't
know. Um, I guess I just, I,
I'm can only be concerned with what's
under my control and so then I'm just
going to train and I'm going to get as
good as I can get and hopefully, you know,
you sought a can, can take
care of the rest. But for me
to stress about it is, is,
is just time wasted I think for
myself. Well, I do know of a case
where there was a fighter who told me
that there was a guy who was openly dirty
as far as what everybody knew and he
knew that he was going to piss hot.
So he went and did some seminars in
another country and just stayed over in
another country for just moved around.
It's like,
so you see this world class fighter,
these weird little gyms. And I was like,
what is going on over there?
And the gentleman who told
me said, listen man, he's,
he's dark and drug tests. That's what
he's doing over there. That's crazy. Yeah.
Hey look, for sure. Like when you,
when the kind of like Tj Dillashaw
gets popped and you're like, wow,
TJ for a world title,
he's getting bopped like how many
people are getting away with this?
How many people got away with it?
It's just not worth it. He lost a
lot doing that. What? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Is that it's not worth it.
It's not worth it.
Ultimately it's definitely not worth
it cause its legacy is tainted.
But if he got away with it,
is it worth it? How many,
how many people got away with it? Here's
the question. How many people retired?
And we never got to see
their drug tests from 2006,
2008 like what were you taken?
Are we on like back when they
used to have those silly wait, uh,
drug tests or their chest,
you at the weigh ins,
which is basically the
intelligence test. Like, Hey,
you still taken steroids or do
you stop a couple of weeks ago?
And the,
the today is so much more sophisticated.
That's why people are getting popped
for EPO and a bunch of things that were
hard to hard to find. Yeah.
They're the thresholds.
Like this is the John Johnson
with the Pika grams, the,
the t the insignificant amount in terms
of like the performance enhancing aspect
of it that is in his system. Like
how can they detect that? Well,
they can detect that because the
machines are way more sophisticated.
The drug testings way.
Like he, if he had tested,
if Jon Jones had tested two years
ago, he would have tested clean. Yeah.
But now it's just, they're just
way better to tie even something,
even if you're taking creatine and
that creatine is tainted. Yeah.
Which is a lot of what these guys,
Tim means that was his deal.
He was taking a supplement.
It was tainted.
Quite a few guys have legitimately just
taken over the counter supplements that
they thought were clean and they got
something just some tiny free that doesn't
have any effect on their performance,
but it shows up.
It'll show up for months and weeks.
And in John's case, like hears,
it's been showing up for like a year
and a half. It comes on and off. Yeah.
And when you're cutting weight,
that's when it seems to come back.
That's what it seems to show because
your body is gone, you're losing fat,
you're losing, you're losing body
weight and some of it's stored in fat.
They think it's very confusing for them.
They're trying to figure it
all out and then the knee,
all these fucking people online or we
rant and rave at about Pika grams and this
and I like the science experts and they
think it's the think it's all bullshit
that John's allowed to fire. You should
be banned for life and like, yeah, okay,
you don't,
you're not listening.
Like he tested negative and then he
tested positive a week later and then he
tested negative a week after that.
Like what's happening here?
Something weird is happening. Figuring
out for themselves. Exactly. Yeah.
But I'm glad they're figuring it out
because now people get to see like,
hey look,
Jon Jones was out for all that time for
other problems and then for the drug
problems. Yeah. Like this is
a lot of money. That guy lost.
John probably lost tens of
millions of dollars. Yeah.
You know, he's still young, he's still
young and he's still out, you know,
and hasn't hit his prime yet.
I don't think.
No.
I think also all that knowing that it
can all be taken away from you probably
met like tempered him,
like put him in a better place.
We realize like I still have
this gift of incredible talent.
If he just a natural born fighter fishing,
he just knows how to fight. Some guys,
they have all the techniques,
all the talent,
but they don't know how to
put it together. Shawn knows
how to put it together.
Yeah. He's just, he just,
that's his, that's his jam.
He just goes out there and he can,
he just does things on the fly that nobody
would ever think of that works. Yeah.
He tries things out.
It's crazy to watch him train cause he's
just super laser done and focused and
there's nothing, you know, there could be,
the building could be getting
bombed and it wouldn't matter.
He just beyond the bag working on
his technique. Yeah. It's really,
it's really cool to watch.
Well
he's, he's the outlier, right? I mean
there's a, there's special fighters.
They're outliers in,
in the sport and for our era it was
like Anderson Silva, mighty mouse.
Jon Jones. Yeah. Those are
the real outliers. Or are
you just watching me just go,
Jesus Christ, like Anderson,
when he was in his prime,
you would watch him and you would watch
them set guys up and it's, he just,
it's almost like he had cheat codes.
Like you could just see
what they were doing. Yeah.
We just like checks and you did that.
I did this and you do that. Okay,
well I'm going to do this and I know
you're going to do that. And Pop.
There it goes. Yeah. And he
would just figure you guys out.
It was wonderful to watch though because
opened up, opened up like a
door for all of the rest of us.
I feel like with any good fighter,
when you watch them fight,
it opens up a door in your own mind.
Like, oh, like that's possible.
I can do that.
And so I feel like with Anderson Silva
did that a lot with his movement,
with this head movement,
with his variety of,
of punches and kicks and the angles
at which they came in from, you know,
and I don't know,
I feel like Anderson Silva did.
I feel like Rhonda did that with her
judo feel like Machita did that with his
karate. Um, and then, you know, I,
I can go down the list of everybody,
but I feel like it kind of like goes
in cycles, you know? And um, I mean,
it's great for me because I can watch
them and I can implement new things.
I feel like that's why I've been able
to be in the game for so long and still
continue to grow and evolve because I
get to watch other people and the things
that they do and like add that to
my, to my tool lists, you know?
Yeah. It changes the expectation of
what's possible. Right. I think it will.
The mighty mouse.
That was one of the best examples of
that because when I would watch mighty
mouse fight, I'd be like, show me
someone who's better, show me, show me.
Show me someone who's ever
been better than this guy.
Like I've never seen anybody
move better than this guy.
Like he doesn't get hit or if
he gets hit, he, it's rare.
Like every three or four
fights on my catches him,
like John Moraga caught him with a good
straight punch like that. That's like,
that was the last I remembered. I'd like
to see him run it back with pseudo oh,
too close fight and very close fight.
And he kind of was so
it blew my mind how like
nonchalant he was about at all.
Like at the end he's like, yeah, whatever.
But that's him. Dj is just a special
guy and he's another one's like,
couldn't be a nicer guy. Yeah. Like
if you didn't know that he was, uh,
one of the best fighters that's
ever walked the face of the planet,
you go along with this friendly guy,
he seems, he's so nice and normal.
It talks like he's articulate. He
doesn't talk like a mean person is just,
it's a great,
it's a great example of like something
that's contrary to the stereotypes that
people think of when they think
of cage fighters. Yeah. You know,
someone is fighting, which is a weird
word, right? Like Kate, like do,
what do you think? Cage
fighting. You do that? Yeah.
Like you're a cage fighter. UFC.
Yeah. You do UFC. Yeah.
That's if you're fighting for Bella
to are people like, what's that?
Is that like UFC? What is
that? What's Bella tour?
Yeah. Catch for changing though.
It's great. I love the competition.
I think that's great that there's more
options out there for the fighters.
Oh, for sure. Yeah. I think it's very
important. I think it's very important.
What's interesting too about this sport
is that it's one of the only sports
where you can go back from 1993 to 2019
and you could see massive evolution.
Yeah.
There's no other sport like that.
If you go back and watch boxing from
93 you're watching great boxing,
worldclass boxing.
Like you could take someone
from [inaudible] 93 and put
them into 2018 like they
would fit perfect. Right.
Thanks. Roy Jones Jr shit,
Rachel's genuine. He's in his prime
today. Everybody be fucked today.
They'd be fucked.
He was just something special.
Bernard Hopkins boxing mentality is like
so old school when you got to stick to
their traditions even it's,
it's kind of like taboo to to see
like fighters switching stance,
which some of them like the good ones
are Josh. Like my husband, he boxed,
you know, and he has a lot, he had a lot
of old boxing coaches that were like,
you don't switch stance. Like you stick
your stance and you perfect that stance,
you know,
out of their fucking mind.
You've watched Terrence Crawford this
one of the things he does so brilliantly.
Yeah.
He,
he is as good as a southpaw as he is
orthodox and it's one of the reasons why
it's so difficult to solve.
Yeah.
Because if you think you got to read
on his timing and then all of a sudden
you're looking gonna Right Jab instead
of a left jab now like, oh shit,
maybe it's,
maybe it's just,
did I watch MMA and more focused
on MMA than I am in boxing.
But when I just from,
you know,
having my husband helped me
out and all this stuff, he,
that's what he's saying
is going to be the,
like the biggest evolution or what has
started to evolve in boxing is that they
are realizing,
okay,
you can use both sides now and
that's going to trick them even more.
Well,
Marvin Hagler was amazing at that.
It was one of Marvin hangers best skills
that he could fight southpaws as well
as he could get fired.
Orthodox Hagler was one of the greatest
fighters of all time, you know,
and he was a champion in the 80s Oh,
okay. You don't know Marvin Hagler? No,
I never already hottie you
don't know the marvelous one.
I never even really watched boxing
until I met my husband. Really?
Yeah. That's crazy. Well, he introduced
you to something awesome. Yeah. Yeah.
It's a good time right now
to watch boxing. You know,
there's so many good boxers.
Yeah. Um, I think that's the,
one of the things that he wants
me to really work on in order to,
to get my game to the next level is my
boxing. You know, cause my kicks are good.
My wrestling's you know,
getting better at my Jujitsu is good.
And if as long if I can put together
my punches and we'll be a okay.
Ready to get that belt.
Karate is an interesting martial art too
that you are really good at because you
have this,
you have an excellent ability to use
that front leg that most people don't.
They don't have, like you have an
awesome front like sidekick, great fun,
like roundhouse kick. And
when you do that, I see,
I see that in your fight
sometimes people are like,
oh I've got to adjust to this.
Cause like a jab. Yeah. By,
but a jab that could fuck you up.
I could shove that can knock you out.
Yeah. I think I, I mean, I
guess like, Oh that to my,
my point find days when
everybody was bigger than me,
it didn't matter because
it was by, by belts. Right.
And so I was always a
smaller one and trying to,
trying to get the point off
first I would just use my,
my front leg and kick it out there
as fast as I could. Um, but I do,
I feel like my, my, my
kicks have lended to being,
I've adopted them as
jobs, you know, so, yeah.
And I love it.
I think it helps it because then it kind
of neutralizes the height difference.
Do you train a lot with
Winkeljohn? I do. Called John is a,
he was an excellent fighter,
a really good kickboxer and
really good at both styles too.
Like leg kick style, but also good at
like he had karate techniques as well. He,
and he's also,
he was very good at those transitions
between those straight kicks and punches.
Yeah. Well, you know,
that's the thing where a lot of people
get confused as like a a no man's land
between kicking him,
punching with people were kicking
specialists and you see it like even with
elite fighters like Raymond Daniels as
he's coming up in his kickboxing career,
it took a while before he could make that
smooth transition between kicking and
punching because Raymond would be on the
outside and he was a world class top of
the food chain karate point fighter.
Yeah.
And then got into kickboxing and
as long as he was at a distance,
he was fucking people up.
But in the transition,
the no man's land between the kicking
and the punching, he looked awkward.
It took a while before he sorta,
so some guys like Joseph Vault,
Eleni and Nikki hold skin.
They sort of exposed that the gap,
the no man's land gap. That's a problem
with a lot of kickers have. Yeah.
They have that problem with the gap
from the kicking to the punching.
Yeah, for sure. I think that's
one of the things that I had to,
that was one of the things
that I had to really work on.
And I think because I enjoy grappling
and Jujitsu that I went straight from
kicking to clench up grappling
and I kind of skipped the boxing,
the boxing part of it. How much boxing
you doing now? Um, quite a bit actually.
Is that your main focus? Yeah, yeah.
Especially off, you know, off camp.
We don't have any, you
know, game plans to work on.
We're working boxing and wrestling.
Now. When you say you work in
boxing, are you just sparring,
boxing and hitting pads,
boxing or are you trying to
implement that into MMA training?
Yeah,
um, I would say both were not sparring.
We're not spying right now. Boxing. Um,
but I was working on your
hands working on the hands,
working on the foot work and then,
so we'll just do strictly boxing,
but then we'll do,
like you're saying the transitions,
so kicks the boxing and boxing,
the kicks and then boxing to take downs.
Yeah,
yeah.
Having things to do when you don't have
to think by knowing exactly what to do.
I'm in this position, there goes
the knee, I'm in this position,
now I'm throwing a punch.
When you see someone going,
oh, like I've gotta do this.
I've got to think. Yeah. You know, the,
the, the, the, those transitions, it's,
it's very, it's a, that
when you're in higher,
higher pressure situations,
that's when those transitions are the
most awkward when you don't have like a
conditioned response.
Yeah.
And I think that's the biggest thing
that I've really been able to work on is
[inaudible] is the blending of all
of them. I feel like so much of us,
so many of us,
we train specific boxing's specific
MMA or kickboxing, Jujitsu,
wrestling, whatever, but we
never really blend it together.
And I think that's the
most important part.
Well,
that's why with George was so great.
George St Pierre was so
amazing at transitions.
Like you never knew what he was going
to do. Yeah. He was so unpredictable.
He was going to punch you or
he's going to take you down.
So everyone's worried about everything.
You didn't know what was coming. Yeah.
That's why I always encourage fighters.
Like even if you're really good striker
man, you got to attempt take downs.
You've got to keep people honest because
otherwise people are just going to
settle in and never worry
about your takedowns.
And then they have an extra degree of
comfort with their striking and you can
get caught what stuff you wouldn't
get caught with otherwise.
Yeah.
And there's just,
I just feel like in MMA you
have so many opportunities.
Like why would you limit yourself
those opportunities? Yeah.
I remember one of my fights,
um,
I was fighting this girl who
was like a 10 time boxer in MMA.
And so I'm like, oh, this
girl is coming into my world.
I'm going to show her what's up.
But then,
and I was beating her the whole
first round, kicking her out,
keeping out with kicks,
keeping out with punches.
I remember going back to my corner and
saying, man, this is too easy. Like, um,
you know, I'm piecing this girl up and
just, just me saying that to myself.
I think something in my
head switch. But, um,
I went back out and ended up,
I think what happened was I told myself,
okay,
your piece in our up with what,
you know,
go out there and beat her at her own game.
Oh Jesus.
Talk to your corner Bro. I told my,
I think it was just like a mental,
like this is too easy.
I'm going to make it challenging,
more challenging on myself. I didn't
tell my corner that it was just like,
you know how sometimes when you're in a
fight you have like a million thoughts
that go through your mind in a split
second. And I think that was one of them.
One of them, oh show this bitch
what's up? Yeah. And at her own game,
which is stupid cause it's MMA.
So I stood in front of her and
then she cracked me and then,
and I saw stars and I stood in front of
her and I didn't take her down and I was
trying to, you know, exchange with her
and she cracked to me again and you know,
I was waiting for her to
stop so it could be my turn
and she never stopped and the,
and I got Tkos you know, but
um, I mean lesson learned,
but I was just so stubborn in,
you know,
in my thoughts that I was like,
I'm going to beat her own game.
What are you talking about?
You're fighting MMA was so mad
at myself after the fact because,
um, I just, I beat myself. I just beat
myself when I went back out there.
Well, that's that old. How did you win?
Or you learn and you obviously this is
something that's still in your mind to
this day. You learned. Yeah.
But that's a part of what makes a champion
like that desire to show I can beat
you anywhere. Yeah. That crazy
belief in yourself. Like,
Oh fuck this bitch up standards
high that those thought processes are so
crazy because the reason why you get so
good in the first place is because you
love challenges and you want to do this
difficult thing. Yeah. So you
literally made it more difficult.
Yeah.
I don't know why I would do that,
but that is exactly why I
continue to fight now. You know,
I think I was nervous coming into the UFC
cause I was coming up from one oh five
you know, I talking to my husband
and saying like, what are we doing?
Like do you think I can make the jump
up and still hang with these girls? And
what would you be fighting in one
oh five the UFC had a one oh five.
Um, I dunno, I guess it just, uh, it,
it would depend. I think it
would have to be worth it. Um,
actually didn't make the cut.
Yeah.
I feel like my last couple of cuts at
one oh five are pretty brutal. Like, um,
[inaudible] fallen out.
Your eyelashes or, yeah,
like I was so shy, jaded
that my like my, you know,
how your eyes sinking and I like,
I remember wiping,
wiping my eye and just looking down and
like a whole row of eyelashes or like on
my, um, on my arm. And um, that's
like when people get syphilis. Oh,
I don't want to die. Start falling
out. I was sickly for Shirley. Wow. Um,
the, you know, they check your,
check your vitals after weigh ins and
the doctor when it released me because he
couldn't find my heartbeat, like
my, my heartbeat for like an hour.
Couldn't find your heart because
you're so dehydrated. Yeah. Whoa.
So,
um,
I just think that also that last cut was,
it was like a,
I did it too quickly. I
think I walk around that, um,
like one 30 to one 30 for sure.
And when you make the cut done with
one 15, how slowly do you do it?
I usually have that eight week
fight camp and as I do like pound,
pound and a half,
two pounds a week.
Yeah. So for you to get to one oh
five. Yeah. Don't do that. That sounds,
that sounds crazy.
Back when the last time I fought
at one oh five I was probably,
when I was fighting at one of,
I was probably walking around at like 25
mm still.
That's 20 pounds of weight
for a hundred pound person.
That is 20% of your body weight.
Yeah.
That's a significant amount
of drain yourself. I mean,
if you think about a welterweight,
losing 20 pounds, it's a good cut.
But an Adam person,
that's so much weight.
I know. I feel, I feel
so much healthier now.
I feel like when I'm in Camp I can focus
on training and having good energy,
you know,
going at 100% rather than going 70%
and then go on to do more cardio.
So I absolutely feel like more healthier.
I feel like I've been
able to put muscle on,
I feel like I'm stronger and just happier,
happier training.
Yeah. What you're seeing
there from so many fighters?
Somewhat and that's one of the reasons
why to go back to this one FC thing,
I love what they're doing that they've
eliminated weight cutting. Yeah,
they do hydration tests on people and
make sure you're not cutting any weight.
And I think the UFC is missing the boat.
They want to test for steroids,
which is fantastic.
100% I'd support that.
They should test hydration to this
weight cutting weight cutting is nothing,
but it's just sanctioned cheating.
That's all it is.
You're not 115 pounds.
Right?
But everybody is going to cut down to
one 15 and then you're probably going to
go back up to like what do you, when
you fight, when you get into the cage,
what do you think you weigh this last
time I got back up to one 28 yeah.
See that's what you're really way like
why is everybody saying she's fighting at
one 15 this is not fighting at one 15
like when you see Tyron Woodley fights at
one 70 no he doesn't. No, he weighs
one 70 you know Kamara Uzman.
He's not one 73 ways.
One 74 a very small time.
What?
Maybe it's just kind of like the
old school mentality or just the,
the idea of that being the last challenge
that you go through before you step
into the octagon. That I enjoy and
not that I enjoy it, but again,
going back to challenges and it's like
one of those things like, all right, like,
you know,
take yourself to this point.
And if you can get through
that without breaking,
then me and you can go to
battle. Right. I don't know.
There's just something to that for me.
I see what you're saying. So it's
another challenge. Like you have a whole,
there's a series of
challenges. Yeah. The training,
there's the mental preparation
and there's a weight cut.
All these things are together
and, and I feel like that's like
the last step. It's like, you know,
it's a battle within yourself.
Is that the death star on your
forearm? What is that? This is,
it looks like the death star from a
distance. Let's try to figure it out.
It's an actual, uh,
silhouette on my husband. Oh,
that's so cool. So it's a
circular silhouette with
the mountains and the trees.
Oh, that's awesome. Yeah, that's really
cool. That's very unique. Thank you.
Does kinda look like the death star
though? From a distance? I was like Shit,
a fucking star wars game.
Actually I don't remember the last time
I seen star wars, but yeah. So the,
the way cut though, the only problem
with it is it's bad for you. Yeah.
I mean I understand that.
I don't cut much. I'd probably cut four
pounds of water weight. Oh that's great.
I hit when I like when
I show up fight week,
I'm probably like three like
four or five pounds off.
Right.
But if you just ate normal we wouldn't
you be healthier give if instead of
getting down within four
pounds of the weight, like,
cause you're going to go up to one
28 the day fight. Right. So that's,
that's an additional 13 pounds.
Where's that coming from?
It's come from somewhere. Right.
So you're doing something.
I understand that the thought process
about talking to one of the doctors about
it.
My last fight cause he was like so strange
that you go through all of this just
to be the same way the next day.
I know doctors are so smart.
I just looked at him like that is strange.
It's fucking stupid is what it
is really is for for the sport.
Not you personally,
but it's what you have to do is
you want to compete in the sport.
I guess just because I've
been doing it for so long,
it's just this in in my head
it's like you know they're only,
a couple of things you have to do as a
fighter. Cutting weight is one of them.
If you can't do that, then you
know it is hard. I feel it.
It's a process that you have to go through
and you have to be mentally prepared
to go through it and if you do it right,
it should only be water that you're
cutting. Even though that's silly to do.
I don't know how it's, it's
silly to do. It's not good.
It's never good to just cut that water.
It's just not, it's not good for you.
But if you do it,
if you,
if you do it intelligently where
you're not cutting too much weight,
it's not that bad. But so many people
are doing these brutal 30 pound wakids.
I just, I feel like at that point it's,
it's not a benefit for you. Like some,
for some people they are the
bigger person coming into the,
to the octagon the next day.
But you're going to reach a certain point
where cutting weight is not a benefit
for you. Maybe, you know, that's, if
you can do it and you pull it off,
especially if you're young and you
figure out how to do it correctly and
replenish your electrolytes, you
know, it is an advantage to be bigger.
But the reality is you're with
whatever weight class that is,
that's not what your way, you don't really
weigh that much. Your weight. It's like,
it's crazy. Like you should be, it
should be about skill versus skill,
but it shouldn't be about who's
got the best scientists. So,
I mean,
so what do you think you think in drag
would still be a one 15 or no chance?
No chance. No, no, no, no.
She's bigger too.
She fucking struggles.
She struggles for one 15 but then
you've got Valentina. I was like,
I think that way class,
it's really interesting,
right when you're talking
about weight classes,
if you're talking about the difference
between 105 pounds in 115 pounds,
it might only be 10 pounds, but it's a
giant percentage of your body weight.
And then you look at MMA in the men's
division and you have, you know,
one 55 and you have one 70 you have
that 15 pound gap. That's a big gap.
It's a giant gap.
I think there should be every 10 pounds,
every 10 pounds for men and for women.
I think there's a real good argument
that should be every five pounds.
But if Dana heard this,
he would find whatever Harris has got
left to pluck them out of. He said,
John Logan to shut the fuck up.
Plucking his eyebrow
hairs.
He doesn't even like the idea of a one
65 I'm like God damn that's a no brainer.
Yeah there is. There's plenty of fighters
out there that are willing to to,
to fight and just give him a place to do.
So in
and guys who would be
champions cause that's there.
They're real natural
weight close betweens.
I think the what one FC is doing in terms
of weight cutting is the way to do it.
But the other side is they're not doing
the same thing that you saw is doing in
terms of steroids.
So they are able to take a hundred
percent hundred percent talk to guys who
compete over there. And it's like,
yeah, I mean there's some, some testing.
So would you rather fight somebody that's
heavier than you or somebody that's
taking question?
Very good question.
Because if there were not just
taking steroids but also taking EPO,
there's a lot of different
shit that people can take,
you know that can give you more like EPO
is a scary one because the person has
more gas in their tank to beat you.
Yeah. They have more, they can hit you,
they can take shots better,
they can recover better,
and then they can come
after you and then they,
they'll have more gas in the tank,
then maybe they can put you away.
Where did we meet somebody that's
heavier than me and depleted from cutting
water weight than somebody that was
taken steroids or equals for sure
for a woman. I think for sure. For sure.
I think there's, for women, for women,
there's a real argument that once someone
has ever taken steroids that you've
altered your chemistry enough and your
physiology enough that you're forever
going to have some sort of an advantage.
So then there's nothing you
can do about that. Well,
I mean maybe deduct a point before you
even get in the octagon that's not even
good enough. Somebody chaos people.
Right? Yeah, that's true. Yeah.
How often do you spar?
Um,
I would say heavy sparring once
a week, once a week. Like, um,
so we do,
uh,
like Emma make grappling on Mondays.
Tuesdays is a heavy sparring.
It's the 16 ounce.
Let's throw down spiring.
Wednesdays is wrestling,
Thursdays is MMA gloves.
Barring.
So it's kind of more just, um, accuracy,
like light on the striking,
heavy on the grappling and then
Fridays technical work technique stuff.
Like
now you're at a gym,
you're at Jackson Winklejohn,
which is one of the best gyms on
the planet earth, but also a gym.
It's filled with savages. I mean, yeah,
there must be a lot of chest bumping and
a lot of people that are trying to test
people and yeah,
there's got to be girls who were there
who look at a girl like you is, hey,
this girl's where I want to be.
Yeah.
And I mean I've talked to males
who trained their say, man,
let me tell you something.
There's some Russian cats just show up
out of nowhere and tried to take your
head off. Yeah. Yeah.
And they go outside and smoke
cigarettes and drink some vodka.
Are they smoking cigarettes? Um, some of
them we, that's weird. Fighters are crazy.
You get the funniest, coolest stories from
meeting fighters all around the world.
Yeah. Jackson's is, is, um,
it's a shark tank. Like,
you're not going there to find emo,
you know,
you find a job. Yes, exactly.
So you've got to give it,
you have to have a good set of skills
before you get there in order to kind of
hold your own right. But we do
actually have an amateur, um,
team right now that is run by Jove is
senior and he's done an amazing job with
the amateur team. And so, um,
we've kind of been able to separate
the classes in that sense where Joey,
um, is kind of overseeing all of the
amateur fighters and he's building these
amateur fighters.
And when he feels like they're ready
to come and train with the proles,
he'll give them the goal, you know,
or, or do a trial run where they,
where they train with us for one week and
see if they're ready. And, um, you know,
for a higher level of the competition.
And then if they are, then they stay.
And if they're not that, they come
back to the amateur team and, and it's,
it's actually worked out quite well.
Oh, that's great. So did they start
people from fresh, like no skills at all?
Some so you, cause there's
classes there for total beginners.
Uh, yeah. It's crazy if you ever
like go into Jim and see like, um,
when you,
when you see like amateurs or people
that have like zero training spar versus
like professional fighters
spot. Yeah. It's crazy.
It's almost looks more dangerous.
I would not want to be in that w in like
the cage with some of those people that
like, because you just don't know where
the punches or kicks are coming from.
They're all coming full blast.
Exactly. 100% control. Yeah.
Jujitsu. Jujitsu is the
same thing. You don't want,
the last thing you want to do is grapple
with a really strong guy was about to
get his blue belt.
Yeah.
Oh Geez. Yeah. Just he goes, gets
in, you know, gets in the way.
I think that's why they match up
high level with low level, don't you?
Sure. So someone can control
you and calm me down and
yeah, I love Jujitsu. I can't wait to,
you know, to get my black belt in Jujitsu.
And,
uh,
I think it's kind of brought me back to
my more traditional background where,
you know, there's a little
bit more structure when you
come, come, come to that.
Yeah.
Yeah. Now how much of that do
you, do you use a lot of grips?
Like do you grab collars
and sleeves and things? Like
I try, I try to force myself outside of
my comfort zone because I am so used to
grabbing wrists,
grabbing shoulders and you know,
right at the crick of the
elbows and stuff like that.
And I find myself going for those grips
because that's just what I've done for
the last decade.
But because I am stepping
into their world,
I want to learn, I want to learn the grips
and I want to learn all of that stuff.
Um, yeah, it's, I mean, it's great if
you want to compete in Jujitsu with a g,
but I think for MMA,
I think the best benefit of Jujitsu
with the g for MMA is defensive for
submissions because you get caught
and things you can't power out of them
because it's not slippery.
Uh Huh. And I'm, I'm slippery. Like I've,
I love Nogi because I can slip out of
things and I'll just wait until I have a
little bit of space and then I'm
all out. Yeah. I'm just glad. Yeah.
And I'm just out, but I
can't do that in game. Yeah.
So what I'll do a lot of times is I'll
go train g and I'll do the technique
class and then when it's time to go,
like do live rolling,
I just take my key off and I go,
Gnocchi.
That's smart. So that way everything
you're doing is applicable in MMA.
Because one of the things we used
to see in the early days of MMA CDs,
g world champions,
like elite level world champions,
and they'd fight in MMA and they lost
all of their technique because everything
was collars and sleeves and pants
and everything was grabbing things.
Whereas instead of now
they try to go to cable,
grabs her over hooks and under
hooks and they were all confused.
We liked their technique is off.
Yeah.
And they would be like a blue belt
or a purple belt world champions.
Yeah. I think it's great. Like my
professor now. Um, he, so I'll,
I'll be rolling with his, with his
wife or some of his students. And
he like, it's weird because they're
getting me ready for my fights,
but I'm also getting them ready
for worlds and stuff like that.
So depending on who's getting cool ready
is what he'll call out if we're going.
And, um, you know, there's,
I'm sitting in their guard, um,
he'll tell them that they have to
get active. They're like, he'll,
he'll straight up say if she was fighting,
you should just be punching the face.
You got to move, you've got
to do something, you know.
So I think it's good just to give
them a different perspective as well.
Have you ever watched combat
Jujitsu? Uh, I've seen a couple.
But where do you get to slap them in
the face and stuff like that? Yeah,
I've seen some of it.
Yeah.
That's interesting because it shows you
where there are these gaps will, okay,
this is an MMA. But if it was, yeah,
you'd be getting pounded out right here.
You can't just hang out. Like there's
moments in Jujitsu that are unrealistic.
And self defense situations.
We're in a fight situation. Yeah.
And that's where I get frustrated.
But it's good.
I need that frustration cause I'll be
in a position and in my head I'm like,
I could just punch you
right now in the face,
but I can't cause they're grappling.
Um,
so your schedule that you're laying out,
is this a schedule of Jackson?
John is just their schedule.
So
yeah, that's what I do in
the mornings at the gym.
So who sets up like when you're in camp,
when you have to,
do you know, you, you've got to
fight. It's 12 weeks from now.
Who sets up your schedule?
Uh, I think what what we do is we
get a fight skeletal then, then we,
we get all the coaches and together. And
so my Jujitsu coach, I go to Gracie Baha,
fruit Jujitsu, so Jujitsu,
wrestling, you know, coach Jackson,
coach Winkeljohn in your,
and my husband and my
husband's with me all the time.
So he kind of oversees everything.
And uh,
we just sit down and we talk about all
the things we need to get together.
I do one pilot with coach Jackson a week.
I do two privates with coach wink a
week and do a private with a coach via
cellular. And then I do all
those in the morning and then I,
and then I work out at my house as well.
And then I do Jujitsu.
What do you do at your house?
Um, it depends on the day.
Sometimes we do simulations
will do like round simulations.
Sometimes it's just hardcore cardio.
Sometimes it's just technical set up
in your garage or something. Yeah.
That's nice. So you got a home gym and
we gotta we got a clear light sauna.
We got a for your health. Um,
what's a clear light? Sorry.
It's like it's an infrared sauna and
then we have a cold plunge. Oh, nice.
And so, and I can get something men
at home, everything. Everything.
If we needed to, we could do our whole
Canada. Oh, that's good. But, um,
I really enjoy being at the gym around
my teammates and around my coaches and
just pulling energy from
them, you know, for sure.
What about strength and conditioning and
how often are you doing that? I just,
Shane, um, I do more strive to
conditioning when I'm out of camp.
So like right now I'm doing strength
and conditioning like three,
four times a week. Uh,
but when I'm in camp,
it depends on my body in,
it depends on what I'm needing
at the time. But I usually
once or twice a week and then I run
just for maintenance just for like
metal, like meditative running, you know?
Nothing hard to like longer
distance but slower. Yeah.
But not even too long. Like three
minutes. The three miles. Yeah.
Nothing crazy that hill that
Jackson loves to throw people up.
What is that all about? That looks
crazy. It is crazy. I mean, it's, um,
it, coach Jackson always
says, if the mountain can't
beat you, nobody can be too,
you know, it's like mother nature,
Mother Nature as a mother, you know,
there's something about that steep
ass hill too. And it's crazy.
The whole team running up at
[inaudible]. It's crazy because, well,
there's that one. But then coach wink has
another one and that one's just insane.
You can't sprint up at you like crawl
up it and it's, yeah, it's ridiculous.
How steep is it? It's so steep.
You can't run. You have to like,
you have to basically
the first three sprints,
there's 10 sprints to
the top and then you,
and then you slowly jogged back
down because it's a really steep,
but the first three you
really can't sprint up,
but you kind of have to bear crawl up
them the mountain as fast as you can,
as fast as you can.
But the one I'm the Hilah tears is,
is crazy because of the
color. The Halo Tiers. Yeah.
It's like it goes up,
it goes up and then it goes up.
So like when you think
you're almost there,
it like cranks up even harder and then
you have to get to the top and um,
it will test you for sure. It
can break you. Well, that camp
was known for its endurance.
Like the fighters that come out of that
camp are known for having great cardio.
Yeah. And how often do those Jackson maker
or Winkeljohn make everybody do those?
It just depends.
Um,
we used to do them as teams
as quite a bit as a team,
quite a bit on the weekends. But you
know, coach Jackson, coach Wayne. Yup. Oh,
that's me. That's my
sister. That's my dog. My,
my Adobe.
It doesn't look like anything really.
No, it looks like it to me. Yeah. I'm used
to running hills. I know what it's like.
That it's terrible. Yeah. It looks
like that. Yeah. That's a feels like,
yeah.
Well it's,
it's amazing how gravity is one
of the best things to work with.
Like get a good pitch,
good steep angle and try to run up
that this is one of the best things for
strength and conditioning for just
conditioning your lungs and your,
your ability to recover.
Yeah. Yeah. I love it.
I think that, um, again,
it's another one of those things that
can,
can really break you.
And uh,
I think it's just like a,
a theme,
like a consistent theme in fighting is,
is will you break,
can you, if you break then you're
not meant for it, you know, or,
or maybe you are and you just need to,
to heal.
Up and go back at it and try it again.
But
when you,
in terms of your mental endurance,
I mean that's what we're talking about,
right?
We're talking about four to two and
your spirit, your indomitable spirit.
When if you go back to when you
first started fighting versus now,
like your tolerance must be through
the roof. Like what you can tolerate,
what you can endure and your
belief in yourself. Yeah.
All that stuff I feel evolves.
Just like your skills do.
Yeah, 100% and, and, but it's crazy
too because you know, we all have our,
our own separate journeys and I feel
like when you first start fighting,
just like when you're a kid and
you jump off of things and you,
you're fearless because you don't
know what it feels like to get hurt.
And then you break your leg
and then you're like, oh,
I'll never doing that again.
You know?
I feel like it's the same in fighting.
Like when you see a lot of amateur
fighters or, or new fighters,
they go out there and they just do
whatever because they're fearless.
They've never been knocked
out there, never been hit.
They never broken anything.
And so they're just going to go out
there and, and, and be fearless and,
and then they get knocked out or submitted
and then the next time they go out,
they're not as as free. Um,
and I think the, the truth,
the true test is to see if, you
know, you can deal with those,
those challenges and allow it to,
to make you grow versus,
you know,
petrify you and make you go
backwards, you know? Yeah.
Do you do any psychological training?
Do you have a mental coach
or a hip and test? Right.
I do. I have a sports psychologist,
Dr. Shannon, and he's, he's, um,
he's been working with me from my last
few fights and I won all three fights.
And I think that's a,
a big reason why for sure.
I,
I think that is a giant overlooked factor.
And some people get
along great without it,
but could they be even better with
it? That's the rule. Yeah, I think so.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There's so much that goes into fighting
that I think people don't see. You know,
I think it's just like
with anything in life,
like how long it takes to make a
movie versus the actual movie and,
and,
and what goes into that 15 minutes
of a fight that nobody even knows,
you know, not just eight weeks,
but your entire, you know,
training before that. You
know, for me it's, you know,
I've been doing martial arts since I was
10 and fighting professionally for over
10 years. And so it, it's an
accumulation of all of those things.
But um,
each fight presents its own problem and
if you're not mentally prepared for it,
if you're not prepared physically for not
prepared, like spiritually, emotionally,
like hormonally, if
that's even a word, um,
everything has to line up that one night,
those 15 minutes or 25 minutes
in order for you to win. And, um,
you can definitely beat yourself
before you step into the octagon.
So what kind of stuff do you work on
with your psychologist without giving too
much away?
I talked to him about this all the time
cause it's like my secret sauce. Right?
But how he explains his is everybody
knows what you're supposed to do,
but you have to put in the work.
Just like physically you have to put
in the work. Like I can sit up here,
I can tell you what I do,
but it's not going to make a difference
unless you actually put in the work to,
to, to strengthen your
mind mentally. Um, but um,
we do a lot of,
um,
so your opponent,
it's not like you can practice barring
them because you've never fought them
before.
Um,
and so how he explains it to
me is it's just a repetition,
you know,
of the mind and um,
okay,
so when,
so you just have to really,
I think explore your imagination.
And um, for us, we,
we practice the fight in her head.
And um,
some days are harder than others.
Sometimes I win the fight in the
first 10 seconds of the, of the round.
Sometimes it's all five
rounds and it's a war and,
and I win that way.
But you have to,
you have to see yourself going through
every different scenario and there are
millions in MMA and you just practice
them over and over and over. Okay.
So it's essentially just
going through that or do you,
do you prepare your mindset
in terms of do is for,
for, for, for me, I have a set of
power where there's what he calls him.
Power words won't tell us what they are.
And so,
um, yeah, I again, um, confidence,
uh, flow vicious.
Um,
thank think I'm trying to see
mom champ.
Mom Champion. Yeah. Cause you
want to be the first mom champ.
Yes sir.
Um,
healthy.
Yeah.
There are a couple of others as well,
but the one word is,
is not just a word. It's
like a whole thought process.
So when I say one word, it,
it feeds into an entire feeling,
if that makes any sense.
And so instead of having to
have a conversation in my mind,
which takes way too long,
I just say confidence and it takes
me where I need to be. And, um,
eventually I want,
you shouldn't even have to do that.
You should just be in the
moment and just allow your,
your mind to connect with your body.
Do you do any meditating
at all? Yeah, I mean,
I would say it's kind of a meditative,
yeah,
I, I would say it's more of, of, of,
of a practice than it is meditation
because I'm not trying to clear my mind.
I'm really trying to focus
on something specific. Right.
But outside of that, you don't
meditate? Uh, I wouldn't say sell.
Maybe just maybe in my runs.
Sometimes when I run I just,
that's when I clear my mind.
How about you?
Yeah, I've been doing it a little
bit, but most of what I do,
I do what I get in the tank. Float tank.
I like float tank. Do you, do you use one?
I have before. It feels like you're
floating in space. Yeah. That's amazing.
Does Jackson's have one? No. They
should have won. We should. Huh?
So if you wouldn't want to go in there
after God disgusting. And we have this,
we have a hot sauna at the gym
and there's tons of people.
There's tons of people. So it gets, could
you, yeah, no, I'm sure the hot sauna,
those different than a float
tank is full tanks. So personal.
It's just one little [inaudible] naked
[inaudible] is they showed me yours and
it felt hotter than the ones that I've
ever done. Is this the right temperature?
Is it? Yeah. Okay. Cause 94 degrees,
that's what it should be. Yeah.
It should be the same as the surface
as your body temperature.
Right? Yeah. Cause it was crazy.
I remember doing at one time and
I kind of drifted off and I remember
almost waking up and feeling like I was
like floating in space. Yeah, sure.
Almost like kind of panicked because
I didn't have a sense of where my,
what my where my body was.
Yeah.
That's what triggers is
weird psychedelic states.
But if you can find one and
use it on a regular basis,
it works great with visualization
and a lot of athletes,
UFC and other sports as well. They,
they use it for visualization.
I till think about passes like throwing
a pass and then watching someone catch
it. They'll, they'll visualize
things and go through the, the,
the technique in their head.
And I've done that with Jujitsu as well.
I've done that with certain techniques
that I was really trying to learn.
You could do it as if you're
rolling, you know, like you're,
you're just like picturing your body
going through the different positions.
Yeah, yeah. That's
basically what we do, um,
with the mental training and,
um,
it probably just take it up a notch
in the, um, in the float tank. Yeah,
I'm sure. But a lot of times,
like when I meet up with my,
with Dr. Shannon,
we meet up at at noisy places
like Starbucks or you know,
or at a coffee shop or something like
that. And it's because he wants, he that,
that life is always going
to have distractions. Oh,
that's interesting. And, um,
you know, you need to be able to
focus with instruction, especially me.
Like there's so many things going on in
my life with being a mother and a wife,
um,
that sometimes I can use the distractions
as an excuse to justify why I'm not
getting things done or this or
that. You know? Right. And, um,
so that's something that I've
really been working hard at is to,
not to not use those as
excuses, but more so to, to,
to allow the distractions to happen and,
and choose to stay focused anyways.
Um,
there are,
there's quite a few
women's MMA fighters now,
but it's still small in comparison to men.
When you meet young girls
that look up to you,
do you recognize that the,
you have, you have a very,
this is a very critical,
and it's a very small role.
There's an in small, in terms
of small amount of people
providing that role. Yeah.
As role models to young kids
that are thinking about fighting.
When a young girl meets you, like, oh my
God, it's the karate hottie like, is it,
is it weird to you?
Like what is that feeling like to you
when you meet a young girl and you say,
Oh my God,
this is me when I was six?
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It really is to know that just through
my story that I've touched people's
lives, you know, um, I get
approached a lot by, by parents,
you know, that are happy that
I'm pursuing what I'm pursuing,
even being a mom, you know, so, um,
I think that's really cool just because
I feel like when I was pregnant,
um,
how old's your daughter now?
She's eight. Yeah. So when I was,
she was much younger for some reason.
I know she's a shrimp.
That's why I showed the pictures
when she was younger. She is anybody.
I I,
this might be too much information,
but um,
after I had my daughter,
she's been to every single
one of my fights. Um, and uh,
I had my first fight back when I was 10
months old and I was still breastfeeding.
I like breastfed
when she was 10 months old.
Now you were 10 months old
when she was tennis. Wow. You had a
fight while you were breastfeeding.
That was your first fight? My
first fight back. Oh, okay.
How many fights did you have before
your daughter? Oh, I had a good amount.
I'd say.
I don't even as you've been fighting for
10 years, professional years, 12 years
[inaudible] yeah,
a good amount.
I was 25 when I had her when
I was pregnant. But yeah,
I just remember being pregnant and being,
everybody talks about like
postpartum depression,
but I was really depressed during my
pregnancy. I mean, don't get me wrong.
I loved being pregnant and there was a
lot of memories that I had with her being
in my belly and me feeling her and
all of this and that, that, um,
those moments I, I treasure
forever, but I was depressed.
Like I couldn't do what I wanted to do.
It's not like I could go out and,
you know, I fell, I was feeling bad.
I couldn't just throw the gloves on and
go out and spar and hit somebody in the
face.
So, you know, like, you know, normal
thing that you do to relieve stress.
And I just,
I,
I've watched everybody get better
and I watched everybody progress and,
and fight and it, you know,
it ate me alive and I just, I,
there was just so much
uncertainty and so much unknown.
Was my body going to be the same, you
know, it was I going to even want it.
Was I going to have time to do it?
Um,
there were just so much that
I didn't know until I was,
I was really down then. And I, um,
I get a lot of moms that approach me and
they tell me that because I went back
and continued to pursue my dream that
they did to, you know, and I think that,
um, that's cool. That is cool.
Now when you say you had your
first fight back 10 months, that's,
that's a really,
for people that don't recognize,
that's a very short amount of
time to rebound from giving birth,
then get yourself back in shape and
then get yourself into a fighting shape.
Yeah. Where you're like, I'm ready to
take a fight and then train for the fight.
I mean that is a incredible
process to go through in 10 months.
It was crazy. It really was.
My body was it when you,
when you have a baby,
your,
your bones kind of like drift
apart from each other and um,
you gain weight. And I, after I had
my daughter, I found out that I will,
during my pregnancy I got
gestational diabetes and um,
and I gained like 50 pounds. I
gained a lot. Like I looked like,
um,
the blueberry on a Willy Wonka.
But
um, yeah, I I,
how long did it take you to bounce
back where you in the gym again? Yeah.
I probably stayed with my daughter for
the first three months that I had her and
I just wanted to be a mom.
I just wanted to be with her and I
wanted to nurture her and you know,
enjoy my time with her.
Uh,
and I think it was after three
months where I was like, I,
I want to take somebody that notes. But
yeah, hold on a, relieve some stress. So,
and coach wink and coach Jackson and
all my teammates were so supportive.
And so I would come into the
gym and I'd have, you know,
my diaper bag in one hand and my gym bag
in the other and my car seat. And I'd,
I'd come into the gym and I'd set it all
down and I'd get wrapped up and she'd
be in the car seat and she chill out
and wow. If she would start to cry,
coach wink or a coach, Jackson would
pick her up and then, you know,
they'd let me spar and you know, she
needed to get, she needed to eat.
I would go to the room and feed
her and then come back and, and,
and we made it work. Wow. Yeah. So, um,
so I started training for that
and I really couldn't run to,
to lose the weight because my joints
and my bones were like all spread apart,
you know. So when you say
spread apart, like what actually
does happen? Well, they,
I mean, I don't know like all
the, the science behind it,
but they just say that in
order to like have the baby,
like everything kind of
separates from each other. Your,
your bones like loosen and you're like
more agile and loose and stuff like that.
And so
felt it, I felt a big
difference in the way your body.
Yeah, for sure. I felt it. And um,
so instead of running I would swim
from my cardio and that helped me,
um,
cause it wasn't hard on my joints or
anything like that and it kind of helps me
get back into shape and you kind of just,
you kind of just go with the
flow and figure it out as you go.
It was really hard.
I was worried that I was worried that
because I got back into sparring and this
and that, that um, I would go dry,
like my milk would go dry but I
didn't, it just, my body just figured,
okay this is what, what you do. And I,
I still produce milk and everything and
it was really sensitive at first to get
hit and, and then I just got
used to the pain and then wow.
How many would have one of those? I'm
like, yikes. Yeah, I would imagine you're,
yeah. I mean, if your memories,
you know, like pump up.
Yeah. It's, it's, the body is just
so amazing though. Like it'll,
it'll adapt to what it needs to adapt to.
And,
and when I trained, I got used to the
pain and then it didn't hurt anymore.
And then, you know, my, I would
only produce as much as she needed.
It was really cool.
Yeah.
Now when you fought 10 months,
it's pretty incredible for your
daughter to have only seen you fighting.
That's gotta be crazy too, right? Yeah.
Can't remember when you weren't fighting.
Yeah.
My mom kicks ass.
Yeah, she has, she has a really cool
upbringing, I think. Like she's just,
she's,
she's surrounded by really cool people.
Like she gets to meet the coolest people
in the world and they're normal to her
because that, you know, she, she sees
John and Holly and you know, that's,
that's Auntie Holly to
her. And so like, you know,
her expectations for, for what she
can be in life I think are way higher,
you know? And I think because she's
surrounded by people like that, that shit.
And that's why I like to
keep around because you know,
my dad used to always tell me that,
um,
we learned through our actions,
our parents' actions. You
know, you walk the walk,
you don't talk the talk.
And so I think the best teacher can be
my actions and for her to see it through
her own eyes. I can tell her
this, this, and this all day. But,
but it's a different story when she
comes to a fight with me and I am the
champion,
the one oh five champion and I'm
defending my belt and you know,
I bust my eye open to the point where
you can't see it anymore and I lose my
belt.
And for her to see that and for her to
see that Mommy's okay and that failure is
a part of life and that I still love
what I do and I'm going to still go after
you know, my set of dreams because failure
is a part of your journey. You know,
that's amazing lesson for kid learn
and to see that at a high level,
growing up with her mother on this giant
stage in front of all these people in
the crowd and television,
that's amazing for her.
Yeah. And because people
ask me all the time, like,
is w w aren't you afraid that she's going
to see you get hurt and this and that,
but why would you want to shield them
from that stuff? I know, I know. It's,
it's hard. It's a hard pill to swallow.
You don't want your children to see you,
her and this and that. But I'd rather
her see it and be prepared for it,
you know? Because life isn't fair. Life
isn't sunshine and rainbows all the time.
Yeah. It's challenging for her
and challenging things for kids.
That's how they grow, you know? Um,
that that's do you have,
when you think about your career,
do you have a timeline where
you don't want to fight anymore?
How old are you now? I'd like to fight
for the belt this year. This year? Yeah.
You're 30,
33 33 so you're in your prime.
Like right now that's like an athlete's
prime is like 30 to like 35, 36. Yeah.
You're in that zone.
Yes.
I'm in the zone. I'm
confident. I feel ready.
I feel like I've gone through
my ups and downs. I've, I've,
I've gone through all the steps that I,
that are necessary for me to be
confident to, to be a contender.
Okay. Do you have a timeline when you
want to stop? I would give myself,
I don't know, it just really
depends on how my career goes,
but I would say three to four more years.
So you're just,
you're just in the zone right now.
You're just concentrating on getting
things done, fighting for a title.
You're not thinking about
like planning the future up.
I would like my children. Oh. Um,
I know my husband doesn't care for him.
My daughter doesn't even care
for me to have challenge.
She'd rather just be the three
of us, you know? But, um,
I would like my children and,
um, I, I have taken steps to,
to figure out what I'm going to do when
I'm, when I retire as a fighter. Um,
but,
uh,
I feel like this story needs to,
I need to finish out the story
from my own sake and for, you know,
millions of other parents out there that,
you know,
have a dream and don't give up on
their dream and just because they have
children, it's a longer road,
but it's worth it. No. Yeah,
I hear Ya. Now when you look at the
division, it's an incredible division now.
So town stacked, we don't know
what's going to happen with rose.
She mean she's even said she might retire.
Yeah.
And she's a very eccentric person.
I mean she's,
she's not motivated by money.
She's very, very unusual.
And I love how honest she is about
her emotions. Yeah, I do as well.
Like she's very vulnerable.
She's very strong.
I mean,
in terms of like her ability to broadcast
that and tell everybody in project it.
Um,
so she was,
I felt like she was winning that
fight and I'm a hundred percent yeah,
she got caught with one of the craziest
slam chaos we've ever seen. I mean,
you've got to go back
to like Carlos Newton,
Matt Hughes to have a slam k like that.
Yeah, I don't, I'm trying to remember.
I guess one, it's one of the best
slam Kaos of all time PD. Tito Ortiz,
Evan Tanner. That was another
one. I mean, Slam Kao is a rare
and I love that it came from the
smallest division in the UFC. Right.
I think that is just amazing.
I'm just so proud of the strawweight
division if I can say so. But I do,
I think it's stacked.
I feel like in from my,
any fight that I have from here on out
is championship caliber fight in my
opinion. Yeah. Um, and that's
why I want to fight for the belt.
Like I want to go for the
belt so that it's legit.
Like we're fighting for the belt,
you know?
And after that it's a championship
fight every time. Yeah.
When you're looking at that division,
do you have those two Jessica on drudge?
And we don't want, again, we do
not know where rose his head is at,
what she wants to do,
but if she wanted to have a rematch,
they probably would set that
up. Then you have you wanna. Um,
you have Tatiana Suarez who's a
beast. You have, you, you have,
who else in the division stands out?
Yeah.
To, um, well, Nina, sure. What Jenna
has to get through Nina first. Sure.
She kind of just write it under the radar.
I don't know.
The, our office, she's Badass
and maybe it's because,
and that's a problem that I've had to,
is that I'm not as vocal,
you know, she just,
she just goes in there and
does her thing. And, um,
and I think that a lot of people are
overlooking her as well. Sure. Um, and,
and that's why I'm just, I'm speaking
out now. This is what I want.
And Joshua's jokes. He says, we
get 100% what you don't ask for.
So, so I'm asking for it.
It's what I want, you know.
Um, but, uh, yeah, there's,
there's widely, um, so
I know that they're,
they're trying to pump
her and she's really good.
I'm coming out of China
and then, um, you know,
obviously Teesha Claudia and,
and even the girls outside of the
top 10 are dangerous. It's, it's,
it's a stacked division and in can go
probably the most talented
division I would say.
So for sure technically and heart driven,
I would say for sure.
Now, what have they said in terms
of like what your future holds,
if they have anything lined up
for you? When do they say, like,
if they're going to come to
you and say, hey, Michelle,
we'd like you to fight in
July or August or September.
Like when would they come to you?
I feel like,
um,
with the way that the rankings are,
are working,
if I just take a fight outside of who the,
who is the current champ,
I'm going to be in the same spot.
I've won my last two fights and I've gone
down and rankings, you know, so I, um,
I,
I really would like to hold off to fight
the champion because I feel like any
other fight is going to either take
me down or keep me in the same spot.
So I don't know what they're planning
on doing with Tatiana and Nina,
but, uh, if they're trying to
give them a shot before me,
I feel like I want the winner of that
and let me in them, hash it out to,
to fight for the belt.
Hmm. So that would be what you would
do as a second choice. First Choice.
Does he want to fight for the belt?
Second choices,
whoever's going to fight for the belt.
Let me fight her.
Let me find them first because
Tatiana only had seven fights.
Nothing against her. Like she's,
you know, she's pled her case.
I have three times the money
fights as she does. You know,
I've fought for about four.
I've been a champion before.
I've gone five rounds before I fought
main event before I've worked my way back
up. Give me a shot. Let me be mom champ.
Yeah. You gotta get there before somebody
else does. Right. That's what I'm saying.
Cause the only other person in that,
well, cats and Ghana, you know, I mean,
I don't know how our
eyeballs doing right now.
I know that was a crazy situation to have
all those fights in the UFC and never
have someone get towed in the, I like
that before. And obviously, you know,
that's how Winkeljohn Boston's vision.
Yeah.
Yeah. It's scary. Yeah.
It is really scary to think that this
is what we do and that there's very,
there's so many dangerous.
Yeah.
I mean you,
you're in a while business lady.
Yeah. But I, I mean, I wouldn't, I
wouldn't trade it for the world. I just,
you know,
this is what I love doing so.
Well that's awesome. Then you're in the
right spot. Well, obviously, you know,
you ranked number seven in the world
even though it is gotta be frustrating
though, that you have
gone in rankings. Yeah.
Yeah. I haven't lost absolutely
100%. And I just, um,
I don't know why they would argue for
me not to get the belt to go for it.
You know, everything's there at
the storyline. Is there. Yeah. Um,
it would be, you know, technique
versus strength, speed versus power.
This is you and Jessica.
Yeah. Yup. Yeah. And um,
and like I said, there were, there,
there were millions of people rallying
behind me because they want to see me,
you know, get that belt.
And I do too. You know,
I'd love for my daughter to see that
dream of mine come true and, and uh,
for her to come in the octagon
with me and be holding that belt,
I think it would be an amazing moment.
Yeah.
It's crazy watching kids see their parents
when titles and how amazing it is to
them. It's, it's a, it's very
strange thing to see like
that, oh my God, you know,
my mom is the champ of the world and
my dad's champ, we've never seen it,
obviously from a woman, but that my
dad's a champion. The world. Yeah.
It's a very powerful thing.
Yeah. So you're in a holding pattern
right now, essentially. Yeah,
that's, that's, that's what we're
doing. Is your last fight? Um,
was it April, March or April? March
or April. Yeah. We're just working.
We're getting better. Almost a year.
No, this April, this April two.
What am I talking about? Yeah. I
thought I thought Carolina cleavage.
That's right. Yeah. I know.
It was a great fight. Um,
I wanted to finish, but you can't
force those things, you know? So, uh,
I just going to continue to do what I'm
doing and continue to get better. And
what'd you think of her loss to on drudge?
That was crazy.
I feel like styles make fights
and it was the perfect fight for,
and Raj to showcase her knockout power
because K K is a pressure fighter and she
instinctively will go forward and throw
when she is in danger and sometimes it
works and sometimes it
doesn't, you know? Yeah.
And she throws hard, obviously
she put, um, you ana, you know,
she buckled you on a couple of times.
She's dangerous. She's, she won.
She won against rose.
Yeah. You know, so, um,
but yeah,
I think styles make fights and um,
that's, that's what happened with her
in that situation. What do you think?
Entourages unusually strong.
Yeah. Look Freakish. No.
Like you see when she grabs a hold of
people and then dumps them on their ass,
like she's,
she's freakishly powerful to be able to
like hit that single and elevate a rose
that way and drop on her head.
When you think about how strong you have
to be to do that, it's beautiful. Yeah.
Beautiful to watch. Um, she's a
beast. Great technique as well. No,
no doubt about it. But man, a
lot of dollar bottle horsepower,
that's her bread and butter.
And
I, and I figured, I honestly, I gave
it to rose to win the fight. Um,
it only takes a split second though to
lose your focus and to get picked up and
slammed it down like that.
And then the fights over,
you know,
the division is actually probably good
because it's exciting because it mixes
things up a bit. You have Yolanda who
is the dominant champion for so long.
Rows comes on to Pete's,
her and then Jessica dumps rose in her
head and beats her and a fight that she
was losing. I mean there's like,
it's a hotbed of talent. It's really,
it's 115 pound women's division is
amazing right now. There really is.
Yeah. Yeah. And um, so
that's what I'm wanting.
That's exactly what I want. And
uh, in the meantime we just,
we just get better and beautiful way.
We train and we get better.
We feel like what's going
to be on Androgel is, um,
I mean rose had rose was doing
exactly what she's doing.
I think that role is actually
kind of got a bit just to,
as a little bit complacent and in
like, she, she's even said it herself.
It was a moment of,
of laziness.
Yeah. And I mean so hard after the fact
to try to figure out what went wrong,
why it went wrong,
what was going on in her head,
but clearly it was not lacing up the
legs when she's attacking the Camorra
elevated and dumped
and, and, and I'm sure for
a lot of her camp she's,
she was able to do that with um,
with her teammates and eat probably
pop off good submissions, you know,
but in the moment of a fight
for a championship belts
in your hometown against
the person that's bread and
butter is a pile drive, you know,
it,
it's just like stacks up against you
for sure. Well good luck trying to
find someone as strong as val is,
her outside of me, Valentino
who she does train with. I mean,
but Jessica and Raj is probably one of
the strongest women in the 150 pound
division.
She's so damn strong.
So good luck trying to find
someone to replicate that.
The training,
you don't train that you
don't train the pile driver.
Like that's dangerous. That's one of those
things that you just, I don't, I don't,
she does train of Valentino though.
Who's one of the strongest
women at 125 Valentino's a tank.
That's a very strong one.
But her style is different
too. Yeah, she's a,
she's a counter fighter and she picks
and chooses when she wants to go and if
she holds you down.
Yeah.
Like her take downs or not unjudged
his take downs. Right. You know,
so I don't know.
We'll see.
It is one of the things that's so exciting
about the sport is that there are so
many different ways to approach it.
There's so many different ways.
Here's your way, karate
style. There's you on his way.
Moitai you know there's something,
there's Jessica's way bulldog get ahold
of you. Take her down and you know,
in a lot of ways you'll want to also show
how to beat Jessica was Raj, you know,
she showed her the beat here.
I just, I feel the difference
with Johan and rose is that
rose, because this is
just my opinion, rose has,
it has shown to have more variety in her,
in her toolbox. She's this really
good grappling and this and that,
that I don't think she's as,
she's not a hazard as hesitant to go
to the ground. I feel like if, if,
if the situation allowed it,
she would go to the ground and even
get a submission on, on drudge.
Whereas with [inaudible],
she knows what she has to do to win,
and she'll be stubborn in that
sense and do that for five minutes,
for five rounds consistently.
You know what I mean?
And I feel like with
rose, she's, she will,
she'll take risks and, and a lot of
times it does work for her, you know?
And sometimes it just doesn't.
Yeah. And that was just one
of those times. Yeah. Just,
it's interesting to see her talk
about fighting in peer period,
that she doesn't know if
she has that in her anymore,
just to be mean to a
person to hurt a person.
But I thought that was really interesting.
Yes.
Yeah, I love how honest she
is, but I also feel like
a big part of her getting the belt
was to know that she could, you know,
to know that she could take down,
you honor the invincible, you know?
And then she did that and
then it was like, all right,
well now I know that I can,
and it's kind of like, well, I've already,
I've already accomplished what I
wanted to accomplish. I don't know.
Maybe that's just me thinking out loud
of what maybe she might be going through.
What might be going on in her mind,
you know,
let's say if you fought on drudge and
you beat her and you become the champion,
would that take a significant amount of
motivation away from you or would you
have more motivation to defend it?
So we'll talk about this too,
because that's been such a huge
goal of mine is to be the champ.
Um, and I, I want to say two fights ago,
we started implementing,
um,
visualizations of me being the champ and
defending the belt and how that would
look like, you know, and, um,
does with your psychologist.
With my sports psychologist
and um, yeah, so that,
that makes the mountain higher. You
know, it's like, it's not the end game.
Once you get the belt. And coach
Jackson would say that all the time.
It's easy to become the champ.
It's harder to stay the champ.
No, Charlie is, well, listen,
Michelle, you're very entertaining.
I love Washington fight.
I hope if you do get the Cha,
the chance of fight for the title,
that I'll be there to call it. And uh,
thanks for doing this. I really appreciate
it. Thank you so much for having me.
[inaudible] everybody get a chance to
get to know you. Thank you Michelle.
Waterson ladies, gentlemen, bye everybody.